hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to extreme treadmill
survival but first happy for the July
berry set up the fireworks
um bang chicken that was the most
pathetic set of fireworks ever seen
berry son of a [ __ ] but either way it
is happy America bang bang day so I'm
gonna be playing something with a lot of
explosions and death at least from what
I saw extreme treadmill survival which
from the gameplay video I fought that it
was like the impossible game but with
much more possibility of death due to
the spikes ever oh hello bomb bomb okay
I thought it my good I thought if I
touch that I would die but either way
this gives another opportunity for me to
show my incredible skill at gaming I
wasn't actually doing too good when I
first tried this
hello mr. cannon oh okay I thought you
were gonna blow up but nope actually I'm
doing pretty well I'm actually surprised
by this wait why am i why am i including
myself to bounce on those no what's all
I was gonna live oh now I've got a hat
and a beard
Wow okay come here ah Amir Amir hey I'm
from Jamaica man I do you suck there's
not allowed to be said about the game
this game was actually made by a dude in
about 24 hours and in that time since
that he made that he has updated a
little bit so that it scales good hook
Hilty a little bit Cana I thought that
was gonna fire right away good bailout
where's the bird well got a bomb Goomer
is that a gun BOM ba ba ba ba Goomer now
I'm a pirate with a beard her are those
cannons mine let me take a closer look
at him let me stick my face in the
barrel of one of those cannons just to
make sure they're not mine maybe I'm
jontron jontron with a bandana because
Jacques is on my shoulder hey wait a
minute we're not a clown or a mime I'm
gonna assume a sad sad clown because who
would subject themself to the torture of
this life
I wasn't gonna do it come on this takes
forever to get scale back up to the
difficulty where I am goodness don't
throw me like that I didn't know okay
that's what happened to the cannibal oh
god I keep thinking that I'm past those
but in reality I'm very not can I go
come on
I know one of these is just gonna be a
troll one yeah you said average buddy
gotcha you thought you could get me I'm
tired to skill this game is actually
kind of fun I mean it's a very simple
game in terms a pixelated style and I'm
not doing too bad you gotta admit I'm
pretty good at games aren't I so that
was good
oh he just died in front of me who's in
the damn thing I can do about it and why
am I so up cause that one went up early
oh no okay come on come on bring it on
Nick Nick going record write record what
is this I promise you in pressing it
looks like it's dynamite plunger and
probably gonna blow myself up ooh did
that go - wait a minute if I bounce up
oh god if I if I somehow magically stand
on a cannon and it bounces off of one
just to go up there like that just did I
make it out of the game why are those
bouncy boobs oh god no no no no what is
that what you're not fooling me a head
poked out his back my head I saw I saw
with my own eyes
nobody moving bus controller dangerous
guys we're getting a lot of tents happy
mother July boom bang boom bang God I
don't know it's like touch Souls if it's
gonna be there okay no what are you
doing no stop it you're my friend you're
not like Telugu Magoo's No who are you I
don't even know anymore I don't know who
I am
I've been survivors as it I think I'm
actually happy
oh by the paddle of meow-meow
oh what am I now my witch why do I have
a W on my head does that stand for witch
or wumbo or Willie wacker or wallaby my
Australian W stand for Australian my
logic is impenetrable because I am
American and that's why I go oh happy
birthday America
hey all right everybody don't look so
sad it's a happy time those are
fireworks let me get a closer look at
that
Oh didn't get me nope not gonna get me
oh don't get me with the spikes those
are basic Jamaica man back
Rastafarianism like that song by The
Lonely Island trying to be talented
ha ha well that pirates peak in Jamaica
Jamaican Pirates time ahead one more man
wombo Willy wacker Oh Wayne is that
Wayne from Wayne's World
Zedd who this is Mike Meyers Wayne world
wound world
Wanhua riding ready swing it was Wayne
Wayne swing swing Wayne hey don't get me
I'm just my if you tried I found out to
beat game I beat the [ __ ] jump
I'll be your dum dum system system off
hahahaha - it's ok walk out bugs it
alone how are you turned on you walk
away from you okaythen em away oh why
Vanessa pop cool guys don't look at
explosions cool
I've been singing about dying my
moustache pink if you know what I mean
it's very classic yeah what monstrosity
are you oh goodness
huh they're gonna die we're gonna oh god
actually yeah okay I'm gonna give up on
the Jamaican accent i'ma go for
something I got a better grasp on oh he
never gonna get it
the Jamaican Scotsman that I am now
you're gonna blame a bloody son
well yeah Kanan I Kings for breakfast um
ah wave your willy Adam wave your Willie
Willie Wow
your Willie Willie Oh blew up obsessive
sad clown parlor life the kids come up
and I try to make balloons for him in
then they blow him up in my face usually
they know that the balloons were
actually alive ten o'clock per what are
the wire Salyer or the world's going on
photo did Santa days of drinking and
hitting and killing all them little
kitties and reindeer I finally catch up
the Santa's on slap me about this ugly
but you want to go home back to my shop
at the North Pole I don't care if Santa
froze his balls off long time ago I'll
sing jingle jungle songs it's on the gay
Santa guys don't let that day be today
or tennis three thousand years old but
God if only I could taste the sweet
bouncy bouncy top I'm on a football
family
I'm Monica Monica oh alright hope you
enjoyed that if you want to play this
game for yourself and I recommend it cuz
it's really fun try to be my high score
of 126 seconds links in the description
along with a whole bunch of other cool
games that I've done happy 4th of July
everyone hope you have a great holiday
there's gonna be one more video coming
out today so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video wrong I did wrong I did wrong